three years ago many banana farmers on
st. Lucia lost everything hurricane
tomas destroyed their fields Giuliana &
Albert satiny had to take out a 10,000
u.s. dollar bank loan today they can
harvest bananas again their plants yield
fruit all year round but the couple
aren't earning enough from their farm
they're barely scraping by when I pit up
but I sin what artists in photo credit
union I have to pay my bills and their
little you remain you have to try to
survive with it so it's hard to prevent
that from happening again after the next
storm the Munich climate insurance
initiative has come up with a hurricane
Insurance Scheme project manager
Subbaiah Becker is working with local
insurer EC global which will sell the
policy the idea behind it is simple a
policy costs 80 east caribbean dollars
per year when a hurricane hits the
insurer will pay policyholders 1,000
east caribbean dollars regardless of
whether the storm has done any damage an
independent weather station measures
rain and wind speed it's an unusual idea
and at first it was hard for banker to
win over and insurer you know any time
you went to an insurance said well you
know there-there's there doesn't have to
be real proof of damage but if wind and
rain speeds exceed certain certain
threshold limits there will be an
automatic payout obviously this was a
completely new concept and it was
difficult for first of all the insurers
to come to grips with it there no
hurricanes then we benefit but when the
disaster comes we also have to pay out a
significant amount of money so there's a
potential there tool to make money
there's a potential there to lose money
we never know what what the extent of
the catastrophe will be how bad it will
be or how severe to learn yeah
proponents have to convince the locals
to here in the village of dennery on the
Atlantic coast they're putting on a play
to explain the insurance scheme everyone
here knows what a big hurricane means
residents were hit
very hard by the last tropical storm 30
minutes later the show is over and the
party has just begun
some people have already decided to buy
the plan
you will give me the forms right now so
that I could feel right now eighty
dollars are gonna feel for many years
because i cannot get an insurance in
santa lucia at this moment to ensure my
business on the seafront in denerim in
the days after the show more people in
dennery up to purchase the policy people
here don't want to lose everything as
they did three years ago